president biden has a lot on his plate
right now from raging inflation cold war
with russia plunging poll numbers and a
ton of other headaches now new questions
over whether he is buckling under the
enormous weight of multiple crises the
president's frustrations boiling to the
surface as he is caught on a hot mic
cursing at our peter ducey and it's not
the first time the president has lashed
out
do you think that that might incentivize
more people to come over illegally if
you guys keep sending that garbage out
yeah why are you so confident he'll
change his behavior mr president
[Music]
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid sound
the president calling peter to quote
clear the air after that encounter the
press secretary jensachi addressing the
outburst earlier
does the president regret saying what he
said about peter peter spoke to this the
president called him he conveyed uh to
him that it was nothing personal man and
also acknowledged that all of you are
gonna ask him a range of questions uh so
i think that uh speaks for itself you
know greg on hannity last night actually
several weeks ago is where it originated
i called dan bongino a son of a [ __ ]
and they weren't even got mad at me yeah
uh well let me expect that from you
you know um you did make a mistake
though you may refer to him as our peter
ducey it's our very own peter ducey
remember it's weird that we don't say
that about anybody else at the network
but we always have to say our very own
peter ducey but biden was right it was a
dumb question inflate will inflation
hurt your chances in the middle of
course it will so actually biden was
correct it was a dumb question but
that's the best part about fox news we
aren't cnn we aren't wetting our shorts
and calling this you know an attack on
democracy or an insurrection every time
acosta acted like a stone tool and got
cnn's cavalcade of karen's you know
fretted about the coming reign of terror
the fact that we find this hilarious and
that we can make fun of peter ducey says
everything about how much fun this
network is but if it were jim acosta
they'd have to change anderson cooper's
sheets carl bernstein would say it's
worse than watergate and also if you
didn't mind trump berating the press you
sure shouldn't mind now i prefer i would
prefer much more berating of the press
and less real world problems that you
mentioned all of those real world
problems that are under biden i will
take that over insults to the press i
think the i think we should be more
obnoxious to the press i do my best
i really am very concerned about the
real world problem in ukraine but i
don't want to be a bummer right now uh
don't you dana think that the
the
the
the hit on biden about his senility
alleged senility and and losing his uh
his cognitive decline isn't that a
little much i mean i mean
that's really not what this is about
really and no and i don't i don't say
anything you don't think it's i don't
say things like that about him but i do
think this there was a
in the campaign when he was in the
basement there was this narrative that
he was the nice older gentleman
who likes ice cream and everything would
return to uh normal or pre-covered right
it would be everything would be okay and
it turns out that he actually is just
like us and he's got an edge and he is
on a hot mic he could get caught we
could get caught on a hot mic at any
moment so i'm a little bit sympathetic
to that but he also showed a lack of um
being able to be nimble even if it is a
dumb question take the opportunity and
talk to the american people and say i
know inflation's a problem for you i
hear about it i heard it from marianne
who was there telling me about the
hamburgers
and that's why i have these people in
here today peter and that's what we're
gonna work on i'm not too worried about
the campaign but i'm gonna like just to
be able to take an opportunity the press
is gonna ask you whatever they ask you
just always like just swing and try to
hit it you rely so much on your mom your
mom uh about my age probably a little
younger than me in terms of your text
guiding you morally and philosophically
even though you disagree now don't you
think that
people are too quick to pull the trigger
on senility and you know all that
i mean don't we older folks sometimes
bring our wisdom
that is i haven't seen any wisdom from
joe biden none at all geraldo no not a
lot of wisdom um
but here's what i think to pete to
compare this to the trump thing the
difference is
is that the media was calling trump a
racist russian traitor and trying to get
him impeached right yeah
our very own stupid son of a [ __ ] just
asked him about a policy question
he asked them policy so
okay
yes like have a little more discipline
i think it's fair as dana said to say is
everything okay because this is not
something that normal people do he's
lost control of the presidency he's
obviously missed the last two waves he's
missed inflation he missed russia he
misjudged mansion so he's feeling shaky
and he's feeling cornered and like you
said you got russia testing them you got
the fed has to make a move soon oil is
going to go up over a hundred dollars a
barrel probably the guy sees the writing
on the wall they give them polling
geraldo they give today they get them
pulling last three polls 40 39 40
approval that's the same as trump not
good geraldo not good the guy needs a
bourbon that's what i would recommend
well i volunteered to help him out there
so uh you saw that press conference
right judge
two hours on his feet a lot of the
questions were just as snotty as uh you
can be yeah you know herald you know
i've listened to all the questions no
i've listened to all the questions
you've asked these three
and you're trying to draw no not at all
you're trying to draw distinction
between age and competence there is no
there is there is a there is a total
difference between you
your older and someone like joe biden he
is losing it i'm not going to be he's
much older than i am well good i'm glad
to hear that eight months okay but
that's where you're going with your
question you are together you are
focused i don't agree with most of the
stuff you say but i still i still love
you okay joe biden isn't like an old
prom couple yeah that's my line the old
brown couple but but but joe biden is
incapable of handling all the pressure
and we see it all the time he's turning
into like a curmudgeon you know like
someone who you know is angry all the
time don't ask me about inflation and
don't ask me about a topic that i don't
want to talk about today because i can't
i can't cover two subjects at once and
you're a son of a bee for asking me that
but go back to grace point he said that
it was a stupid question but that's his
no such thing as a stupid question
but here's the bottom line he wanted an
answer from joe biden joe biden couldn't
be nimble like dana suggested he
couldn't address it because he was only
focused on that one thing and i have to
give credit to dana if you recall when
this broke yesterday who's the first
person who said if i were if i were
talking to the president i would say you
got to pick up the phone you got to call
our very own
peter ducey and just you know make
things right and that's i think that was
a pretty uh i think that they i'm sure
that jen sackey that was probably her
first thought i want to say our very own
dana princess very own peter ducey was a
class act because he went right past it
yeah and he treated it like it was
nothing he loved the class actually he's
our very own
so do would you ever say our very own
geraldo yes yes we can now say it our
very own herald hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else